I just told ya
by now you've spent 10 grand on Dan
Locke products the opportunity costs
totaling with scholarships and
everything else of just kind of wasting
time on this HDC thing is fifty thousand
dollars yeah I don't like to hear that I
know I know I got a look at that so did
you relate when when when Garrett said
this was a cult that was yeah pretty
happy I hate it the mindset I had so
much during that time because it was
very much you know in order to justify
everything that I had done at that point
I almost had to like automatically
belittle others just just to put myself
on that pedestal to think like I'm on
the route to success hi there we go I
never heard of the mantras that Dan
Locke has for everybody he's got mantras
for people to say every day you are
every day so in line to me and then you
have to listen to them to at night 1:00
in the morning and it was like humans -
Dan - yeah I won't that's basically what
it was because the whole time I was like
just basically Dan Locke I've got to
tell you this is one of the strangest
things I've ever heard so he's got you
have to listen to seafood three times a
day yeah every single day and there were
people that actually did so how have we
gotten this deep into Dan Locke and no
one has told me that no wants to talk
about
welcome to fake guru guys this is part
two of our expose on den lock now as you
guys know last time we had Garrett the
teacher who lost $26,000 from being in
Dan's course for the consequences of his
decision to join Dan's course and then
the related upsells that triggered a
gavel and shove emails into my inbox and
you know we can only pick so many I was
lucky enough to have Anthony come
forward and want to want to give his
story as well and I think it's really
important to just keep hearing from you
guys so thank you so much for coming
forward Anthony I appreciate you taking
the time to tell your story yeah no
problem and also the lighting here is
gonna be a little bit off-center cuz
watch what happens when I do this yeah
very blinding but otherwise in the dark
here best I can do on my own but I'm
ready to talk about this cuz it's been a
long time coming I gotta say it's just
been one catastrophe after another now I
of course have to accept my fair share
of the responsibility of course nobody
forced me to buy anything right like
there's no pressure in any case it was
me wanting to join in and start where I
wanted to go and with my debt
dissatisfaction with what I was doing
before and so but you're just telling
them on the quinces of that decision
exactly exactly I'm just telling people
the consequences of my decision so with
that in mind I guess the best place to
get started is well exactly where I was
at when I started HTC so HTC I don't
remember if Garrett had mentioned in his
videos but they have a different season
so essentially for the seven weeks that
you're in the course seven to eight
weeks they'll group you up in two
different seasons based on when you join
so for me I was season four and that was
actually around June of 2018 so
setting the setting all right so here I
was at the time I was 17 actually and I
just got my high school diploma did my
graduation party I had been saving up a
lot of money which this is important
because this will come in later as I
explained just the timeline and all the
crazy [ __ ] that happened I had saved up
roughly ten thousand US dollar of my own
money you know just working part-time
job at a gas station for a year and a
half and then I was fortunate enough to
have a college education fund which my
father provided for he had put twenty
two thousand u.s. dollar into that
account now I had of course set up the
expectation that I was going to do
phenomenal things you know at the time I
was like yeah you know I'm going to
college early like during high school
and shed and you know I want to go be a
doctor and it's specifics interventional
radiology and then I found that
interventional radiology and diagnostic
radiology in particular is currently
being replaced with automation on
technological automation so this started
to feed into like you know kind of the
fear of what what am I gonna do got
introduced to a bunch of like Dave
Ramsey's content really good stuff and
eventually started building into
YouTube's algorithm that I was
interested in a lot of this business
acumen and a lot of the financial stuff
and how to make a lot of money and sure
enough I got on to Dan locked content so
here I am I'm finally wrapping up my
school and I'm learning more and more
about Dan's stuff and I got to give it
to him the guy knows how to make great
content and when I found the yeah
actually Erin mentioned in the previous
video with Stefan James you know there
was that webinar the wealth triangle and
whatnot so here I am I'm Stephan James
is what part of what helped you get into
the course yeah yeah and the funny thing
is it was like the first and only
Steffan games who have ever watched so
hi Stefan Stefan James has some serious
skeletons in his closet you don't know
about it really no I have no idea the
people don't know about it the people
are gonna know about it
but oh it's bad it's really bad yeah
Sean may be worse than Dan Locke I don't
know it's because I'll have to stay
tuned to that [ __ ] yeah yeah that's a
yeah Stefan James alright alright yeah
yeah I'm so it was like the first and
only video of his that I watched and of
course my impression on watching you
know this thing yeah this is you know
this is pretty good and then I tell that
Dan was also went in now I was like
pretty cool and then they mentioned the
webinar and you know of course I signed
up so I watched it and I got my way
through it and then of course it was
like alright so we're gonna present to
you the high income skill which you know
makes sense electricians they get paid a
lot of money because that's a high
income CEO and sales is also high
incomes both tangible real world skills
of high market value and when I saw the
high paid closing program I was like man
you know if I can learn how to do sales
because my stepfather's in sales and he
makes really good money if I can do that
you know that would be awesome because
then I wouldn't have to go to school and
you know not have to spend all that
money because I also wanted to earn my
way into Canada to be with my girlfriend
who at the time I had been with three
years at that point and you know we were
looking to close the gap and we're still
together our anniversary was actually
this Sunday so I was pretty fun
congratulations thank you thank you for
years for this time and it's been a hell
of a year in between I'll tell you that
so if you can imagine yeah especially
what you're gonna hear so yeah so where
was I again I was talking about yeah I
see you want to get the high income
skill so you don't have to go to college
you know yeah go be with your girlfriend
in Canada it kind of expedites all of
this you don't have to waste time go
going to a job you going to prepare for
a job that may not be there when you get
there exactly yes so with all of these
factors in
and just these doubts starting to creep
up in my head like well man if I stick
with what I'm doing how do I even know
that's the right choice like how does
anyone know anything's the right choice
you know am I gonna regret not doing
this program and of course I saw the
price on it and I was like okay and I
was like I got maybe 300 under that in
terms of total graduation money I'm
chipping in 200 or my own money that
shouldn't be too bad if I can pound this
out over the summer I'm joining in June
right if I can get this done by July and
freakin you don't get an influence or
close sales I might not even have to go
to school and I'd still be able to stay
in Canada because I'd be in maybe you
know within two years I could hit the
net worth required to just go into
Canada and start an enterprise I get it
I kind of figure this [ __ ] out so of
course I join the htc program now going
through it the first time you know I I
gotta say the information hasn't really
helped me much at all just from like a
consumer review sort of way of looking
at it I haven't used the information
once since I got it so if I could really
estimate what I would have paid for it
it would have been zero but I know that
I made yeah yeah we're saying the course
is worth $0 to you which is I pretty
much say to everyone if you're faced
with the course that they're gonna
charge you $2,500 for don't buy it
it's yeah I will say it's never worth it
but you know God you guys know what I
mean by that let me get this straight
let me recap this so Dan took your
graduation money and then some yeah
promised you a dream right yeah you're
stressing out about college because
everybody is worried it's true that the
economy is fragile right now so he's
taking advantage of your fear fear for
your FOMO fear of missing out on some
new ride edible opportunity awaiting you
okay so then what happened so you you're
starting to get to the end of HTC yeah
so it's July now in this time
and I'm finishing about HTC and I was
thinking okay I'm gonna get an
influencer pretty soon I better be ready
you know I'm gonna attend this last
class and then how it worked was me
moving to Canada to start my student
visa was the day after my final htc
class so when that came up I was like
okay a little bit anxious here because I
got to make a 13 14 hour drive in the
morning and like I'm gonna be up late
doing this and I want to make sure I'm
doing it right because I wanted
influence I wanna make money I want to
not have to be able to go to school and
if anything have those results before I
even start school which I believe was
supposed to be in September and so sure
enough go through the whole thing and at
the end is a carrier dimension there was
the upsell to inner circle so I was like
well she had I mean if I'm gonna be make
it here's me being a dumbass if I'm
gonna you know no dude dude dude - dude
everyone blames himself and I don't know
why the course is carefully constructed
to make you feel the way you felt I want
you to know that like you're blaming
yourself like I shouldn't believe that
but literally you're believing what
you're told to believe I want to stress
that so say what you believed right say
what you okay okay I so at the time I
was thinking well you know what how
about how about if I invest this extra 2
grand which to me I can take that right
out of the money I earned working at a
gas station you know that does not touch
the college money that my father has
generously put aside for me and then
that extra 200 well he'll be making that
you know so 200 a month that's not bad
like to have this inclusive access to
the team you know team Dan lankan be
able to kind of put my name in the
spotlight right because Dan Dan
basically pitches it as this guys it's a
$2,000 up so with $200 a month $200 a
month but Dan Dan's a lot of Dan's pitch
and correct me if I'm wrong is you guys
will be making so much money I mean you
believe in your own success don't you
you want to invest in your own success
don't you what
aren't I Dan locked the high-ticket
closer Sifu aren't I worth the $2,000
and $200 in value a month
aren't I worth that and that's how he
gets people to buy in and go oh well of
course I bet on myself
he turns it into like you you're not
betting on yourself if you don't join
oh yeah and but the the biggest thing
was so the funny part is that wasn't
even what sold me on it and of course I
saw a lot of people that I you're gonna
love this because I don't remember if
Garrett mentioned it or not but I mean
of course I saw a lot of people that a
lot of new friends they were like oh I
joined I see and the group chat and
everything and I was like okay starting
to tempt me now but the real kicker was
at the ends it was supposed to be this
deal with Salesforce I believe is what
it's called where essentially it was
supposed to be exclusive contracts for
inner circle members and if you were in
you essentially got to you were first on
deck in fact you there was supposed to
be special training for Salesforce and
you were supposed to start off working
some contracts if available so of course
it was wait you were told that Dan had a
contract with Salesforce and now I'm not
sure if it was a contract or like it was
just a mutual agreement between them or
something but I know that they were
involved and then the guy who runs
Salesforce sales for Samba at the time
he made a video with Dan explaining how
they were gonna do it you as part of the
training calls and whatnot and then of
course they just fell apart one day I
don't remember what the explanation was
I know there was one at the time but
like everyone who had already spent all
the money like we couldn't say anything
about it also would get kicked out it
was like well we don't want to be kicked
out cuz what if there's something next
but that's sort of but but the promise I
mean that's maybe some of the reason you
bought in is cuz sales for all I know I
know a lot of people sell super legit
cuz of that
and I'm one of them I only bought in a
circle because I figured well [ __ ] I
mean I'll be able to work because how it
was advertised was you know if you buy
into inner circle you're gonna be able
to have access to companies like
Microsoft a CMT and a couple other logos
and stuff and it's like they're gonna be
through Salesforce they're gonna be
knocking down to your door and they're
gonna be babies actually I think it was
something along those lines where it was
like they're waiting for you it's gonna
happen and sure enough I was like well
[ __ ] I mean if the contract if the
agreements there then I'll go for it
because then again and maybe uh maybe
just maybe I'll have the money by the
end of August or yeah if I was starting
in September maybe end of August I'll
have the money where I won't have to go
to school and I can stay in Minnesota
for a little bit longer and then come
back with the 300,000 or whatever and
visit my girlfriend all the time because
I don't have I can work from home right
so ya know [ __ ] me that didn't work
makes me so sad because this this whole
course preys on young people who are
full of hope full of hopes dreams
self-confidence dare toddlers gas
station money dude there's more than
that the best part there's nothing
people work so hard for their money when
you're working a minimum-wage job or
slightly above minimum wage every dollar
matters so much it's like oh sucked I
mean just knowing that it was spent for
nothing but the worst thing which of
course you'll know you already known
from what we've talked about already but
what the viewers will know by the end of
this we haven't even touched on yet the
thing that just kills me inside even to
this day it still [ __ ] me up a bit so
moving on in this timeline so here I am
joined inner circle and actually I did I
did manage to find an influencer almost
immediately had nothing to do with
Salesforce
whatsoever this was just me going off on
my own through LinkedIn and I found
someone and I worked with them so an HTC
we were taught no cold calling ever bad
can't do it it could only be inbound
warmly but the thing was is that with
this cold calling situation like I was
always like I'm not supposed to do that
though like I don't know maybe I'm like
a failure as a closer because I have to
call companies or something it you
should have seen how weird it was like
just sitting if you if you announced
that you were doing any cold calling you
were ostracized just for that not by
anyone on Team Dan locker and high
authority it was just the community
members because it was so preached again
it was yeah it was so like taboo almost
it was just weird as they are I I don't
get it either really common I I mean
that's what marketing is it's just you
know the digital or like a billboard a
hardware version of gold right yep so
yeah I I was like man you know I'm gonna
have to keep this operation under wraps
I'm gonna have to keep it pretty low and
of course the entire team that I was
working with with that gentleman was
also from HTC so they had all found him
as well and we were all working together
and he had long story short not a single
person made us say all that and we all
blamed it on so many different things
like just all dumb stuff that I I think
my personal reason was I just didn't try
hard enough oh no also you're a beginner
salesman I mean you have no real like
even the idea of sales training sales
training starts when you start actually
selling to real people I mean I'm not
gonna say that sales as a supplement
isn't good but exciting that people can
learn sales in a classroom without
having like boots on the pavement just
have that experience is ridiculous so no
I again I would
put that on you I would just say there's
not much you can expect someone no
eight-week course is gonna prepare you
to be a Salesman you're still gonna
start a total beginner yeah I understand
where you're coming from and personally
when I was when I was going through that
I think if I remember correctly I was
yeah I was like nervous as hell I was
anxious I could barely pick up the phone
and call these companies especially like
the disaster is cold calling you know
like you're interrupting their day but
if someone is calling you that you're
the one in authority so if you're
calling them you have no authority and
just all this stuff that's stuck in my
head it was all I was thinking wrong I
could think about in back with HEC just
concurrently me with an influencer
thinking well I don't have to go look
for another influencer I've got one and
then also me failing with my influence
okay so maybe I should or shouldn't know
who knows what if else or should have
been going on with all that but still
paying 200 month in the meantime to
figure it out right so and you're just
bleeding money at this all just like
like someone's stuck me with a knife or
my wallet for instance but like hell
like leaving money right in the Dan
locks pocket yeah yeah and the Ontario
gasoline prices that was that murdered
me not having any income at all at
trying to pay gas in Canada as a bad
idea so the combination of the two
roundhouse kicked my bank account and
yeah I know I was I was pretty
demolished I was actually by the time
closes and black came up I was wondering
how I was gonna pay for it now I went
from closers and black cost so it was
supposed to be free with inner circle
and then there was an optional VIP
upgrade where all you had to do was
submit 200 bucks US dollar and it was
refundable or like it was refunded to
you upon arrival so it was just a claim
respond the VI
he or whatever and then of course from
where I was flying I think tickets were
like I think it was like 500 person and
I brought my girlfriend with because I
wanted to take her out to Vancouver
while I was out there and so when we
went out there hotel we actually got a
pretty
I know Garrett was he was dressing on
the point that you know see who said we
had to stay at this hotel yeah I mean it
was cheaper than all the other hotels so
I mean I didn't really mind that too
much but overall I think the trip cost
me like maybe 2 grand mm-hmm you know
that that's with like food and like dumb
[ __ ] like that license plate up on the
wall behind me but so when we got there
that $200 refundable thing of people
were standing in line they're like okay
yeah are we gonna get our children books
because how it was supposed to work with
you know you deposited and then they
hold onto it for you
when you arrive they get it back and
that's supposed to be your spending
money for when you're there okay well it
turned into you put in your deposit you
go there when you arrive they tell you
that they used it for the VIP option
which includes the catering and food and
all that and that you wouldn't be
getting it back because now you're
automatically automatically upgraded to
like VIP which is wait sorry why sign up
for ya no nobody I know it's 200 bucks
and you've already spent like for $4,000
I know but like that's that's the
thinking it's still hold on hold on hold
on oh no no no no no no Don you were
told you're just gonna get a refund erst
and this and then just do you just show
up and it's not he just doesn't give it
to you ya know it was it was like whoa
because you opted into the VIP and now
that that money's been allocated towards
your VIP stuff and it was like I don't
even remember that VIP advantage well I
don't remember what it was it was like
let me ask you at any point here are you
thinking I thought there may be off
something wrong here what's going on
yeah so when that happened that was
actually weirdly enough that was the
first time that I started to feel that
something was weird and of course the
conference hasn't even began yet we just
were at the hotel you know we're just
speaking with the team we're getting all
their badges and stuff signifying that
word that the events and it was just
like well [ __ ] you know like that's just
kind of low-balling it you know kind of
telling people that thinking that was
supposed to be their spending money
because I didn't bring anything other
than like maybe 200 bucks myself for me
and my girlfriend you were too old that
you're gonna get your 200 back we're
gonna get the 201 we were there yeah
exactly and I hate the heart Harper at
this point but this is like very
emblematic of the way Dan rolls you know
yeah tell you one thing oh yeah
Salesforce oh yeah so Scott would
basically we almost have a contract with
them of course they're gonna be Amazon's
Jeff Bezos is gonna come to your door
and ask you Anthony please come work for
at least I axes yeah nah and then we
don't get in when you actually pay the
two grand that's 200 bucks a month he's
like oh yeah that Salesforce thing I
felt through felt yeah and man that
sucked because we're also supposed to
get a bunch of specialized Kavon videos
and they were supposed to be basically
just supplemental lessons because as
gary said once a month you got a new
lesson or whatever and then of course
you get the dinners with dan which was a
facebook live and then so he did those
of course and then there was also
supposed to be a cave on on demand which
they didn't they pushed it on super
backburner and then around the time cave
on i think it was like a couple weeks
before he you know he left that CIB
that's when he made his announcement he
was leaving oh they finally announced it
or they released like all of it at once
i choose from the way it was it looked
like it was all filmed in the
so they released all of it at once and
then once he left I don't remember so
this isn't a fact this is just me trying
to go off memory
I believe they took all of it down when
he left so they only got it for like
three weeks or so every month and I was
like oh okay thank you but a lot of
people seem to this cave on Dan Locke
split seem to affect a lot of people he
yeah because there were people closing
for cave on two separate separately from
team deadlock they were closing for
whatever cave on had going on
they were pretty secretive about it
understandably enough you know so yeah
when this is lilac yeah oh yeah and cave
on didn't tell any of his team that he
was leaving so when they were all like
folders in black and then he was
announced that he was leaving they were
all like well [ __ ] are we still gonna be
on the team like you know that was our
I'm assuming from most if not all of
that was their income was doing that so
um them I mean from my understanding
they still got to stay on the team but
then they just want to do whatever K
bond was doing so you know I I hope that
it worked out the best for them because
I haven't heard anything about it sense
but yeah so that's pretty much all I
know about that other than I believe
some people go up on stage and say it
would you jump off a cliff if Dan lock
if Dan lock was behind ya it was I think
it was I cave on or Desmond just for you
guys who remember Desmond and cave on
were like Dan's right-hand men and cave
on ended up leaving Desmond is still
there in the last video Garrett told us
that yeah it's a bit of a weird shock
while he's prepping everyone to say yes
to us
he's basically saying you know I trusted
Dan you should trust Ben too and then he
goes look guys if Sifu got up behind you
and you're on a cliff and he told you to
jump off that cliff
would you do it and apparently people
were like yeah yeah actually there was a
lot of people that went like yeah and
myself I just kind of like know I'm a
naturally introverted guy so I don't
express myself too much so I was sitting
there just kind of looking down at the
ground because I believe we're all at
one point we all had to stand up put our
arms in front of us and then just kind
of look down and we had to like recite
the freakin closers in or the Heidi
codes or creed or whatever which I've
only read like once wait why don't we go
to the high-ticket closet Creed until I
only read it like once you know it you
don't know it I don't know it so he they
were reading it off and I was just kind
of like sitting there you know come on
your lip-synced you got a decree yeah
yeah that's why I created because you
were supposed to the daily activities
you were supposed to do and I took a
pose a program was and I didn't do them
I just thought it was I couldn't get
into it I tried like I genuinely tried
and thought nothing of it weirdly enough
I was like this is how I'm gonna you
know this is how you're supposed to do
it to get the right mindset in order to
be rich and I just couldn't get into it
so what you were supposed to do was
every day you're supposed to read the
Creed at least once aloud to yourself
and then you were supposed to when you
went to bed you're supposed to listen to
these two audio things of Dan speaking
for like both of them were like 14 15
minutes long and then in the morning
you're supposed to listen to another one
and it was just yeah every single day
and
have we gotten this deep into dan lock
and no one has told me that no wants to
talk about I never heard of the mantras
that Dan lock has for everybody he's got
mantras for people to say every day you
are every day so enlighten me
I have the Creed somewhere buried in my
archive I rock receive but like dude he
makes you listen to tapes of him look
guys it's like he is he has them on
YouTube I don't know if they're still
there but they were the same ones from
YouTube he pulled them off they put it
into an mp4 file and then you have to
listen to them to at night and 1:00 in
the morning and it was like - Dan - yeah
I well that's basically what it was
because the whole time it was like
basically it was pretty I was sitting
there and I was like I can't get into
this like I hate ASMR as it is I don't
need like this is some like hero worship
stuff right here man like this yeah this
is weird this is so weird
I've got to tell you this is one of the
strangest things I've ever heard so he's
guys you have to listen to seafood three
times a day like any times it's like a
ritual like like you like like you know
you pray five times a day you listen to
ceases three times a day you get to the
Cecil we know they even said it the way
that they put it was every every week
there was assignments right so yeah
one of the assignments which is
consistent with every single you know
day of the week or whatever then they
wanted you to do also a daily thing was
to watch at least three of his youtube
videos every day on top of the three
affirmations on top of reading decree
and if you can hit ten videos in a day
then you know you're a [ __ ] all-star
so it was it was trying to find this
fine line in between they I don't
remember if they solicit Lee said this
but essentially the point driven was you
had doing gross yourself into the
content
because then you become a better closer
you know if you do everything step by
step that Dan is doing then of course by
default everything that you learned
you'll be able to use in order to become
like the master closer you know and I
mean you can tell what some people you
can tell the people that were doing it
from the people that weren't because the
people that were doing it had a
different Moxie to them when they were
speaking on the like in our practice
chance for the role plays and like they
would rack up hundreds of hours in the
role plays and but the thing is like the
people that racked up hundreds of hours
in the role play is they like never
gotten influencer you know they never I
shouldn't say always busy listening to
Dan my man cuz that's the how Keith I'm
I'm you know that was that my mind is
that you know if you're engrossing
yourself in the content all the time
like some of these people is so
full-time jobs they they don't got time
they got kids you know they got
responsibilities much more than I did at
least and like trying to find a time to
reach out to influencers and listen to
30 minutes of r45 with the morning one
of Dan ASMR and a day and got down like
are you listening to the same one every
day it was the same three everyday yeah
so so it's like yeah so they weren't new
by any means and I believe I believe I
haven't checked for myself because I've
banned myself doctrine aiding yourself
that's part of the policy is you would
doctrine eight yourself forty five
minutes in the morning right or fifteen
minutes in the morning how many I think
it was fifteen I never got until in
thirty minutes at night and then say
your clothes Creed committed every
single program Wow Wow as well as post
on the Facebook group every day which
you know video is best so post your
videos on the Facebook group every day
send out a hundred messages and find
influencers every day you know if you
didn't already have an influence
so did you relate when when when Garrett
said this was a cult that you were you
like oh yeah
hashtag relator hey that was yeah pretty
hashtag really yeah so that was
interesting enough on its own just to
come to the realization later because it
was after closes and black that I
started to think that was weird now why
I didn't think I was weird beforehand
probably because I've never had to do
something like that yeah cuz you know
I've never had a sociology teacher tell
me to listen to 45 minutes of sociology
ASMR before every day oh I don't know
why he also tells you to not listen to
other gurus while you're taking his
thing right now that's a very fine line
because how it worked was there were
constantly fights between the
communities not necessarily the teams
but the communities like for instance
the Grant Cardone community would pick
fun of the damn Locke community and they
would butt heads for a bit and then
eventually team Dan Locke had to submit
a statement saying guys we have no
reason to hate them they have no reason
to hate us but it was just sort of sad
in the first place that they had to even
step out and say guys why the hell are
you wasting your time with this but I
guess people just took it as a general
rule of thumb that if you weren't
following the htc lifestyle then you
weren't worth living you know like you
yeah you weren't in the family they
weren't in the family the brother and
sister you're not my brother hey who's
my family look look at my look at my htc
brothers and sisters they're my real
family yeah really
like there was a some I just I hated the
mindset I had so much during that time
because it was very much Yul's
in order to justify everything that I
had done at that point I almost had to
like automatically belittle others just
just to put myself on that pedestal to
think like I'm on the route to success
and if I didn't automatically do that
which I'm ashamed of that I don't like
that at all
and I did that but I'm gonna admit that
I did it if I didn't automatically do it
then if I'm on the same ground as
everyone else then what is this
so-called advantage that I chose to
invest in doing for me you know if I'm
just if anything if anything if you're
comparing how much I'm making versus how
much I'm spending if it's lowering
myself from the rest of the crowd that
you know maybe for instance I only told
my girlfriend this but when I was at the
University in Canada I could not make
friends with people I was so arrogant I
was so like I just couldn't take the
other students seriously because in my
mind I was thinking well I'm this high
ticket closer right like I'm on my route
to success I don't even need school why
the hell am I here I'm wasting my time
and money all these other students you
know they're they're like a joke
basically like you know they're not
serious about their life now like I am
and it was it was just sad you know so
I'm really glad you said that I think I
don't think it's anything to be ashamed
of I think he was a form it sounds like
a form of like psychological protection
you're trying to protect yourself from
like realizing what's going on and oh
yeah because once I came around to
realizing my mistakes I was like yeah
[ __ ] me of this hurts so okay yeah it
was pretty I think a lot of people will
be able to relate to that I mean really
truly if you're an htc right now you
might have done the same thing or be
doing the same thing right now
exactly yeah like I really really hope
that a lot of the people that were an
htc that left or even the ones that are
still in there but just scared to leave
I really hope they're doing okay and
that they invested
I know I know for a fact there's some
people that invested into the program at
the worst time they could have liked it
just was not in their favor to do so
like selling your car and quitting their
job in order to make time and have
enough capital to get in and then they
still you know carried on with it and
they got nothing out of it I that makes
me so sick because I thought I had it
bad you know there are people there that
had that's happened to them yes yeah
absolutely I know for a fact because
I've talked to some of them and I know
all the Garrett mentioned that to us so
and I also know there are some people
that you know they had a little bit of
money to their name just like I did and
maybe they're not dead I'm happy to say
I never went in debt but after it was
all said and done I had $40 so from
going to events the US dollar so from
going to from 22,000 college funds and
10,000 from a gas station money and on
top of that I forgot to mention it at
the beginning of this but I had 16,500
and scholarships that I had got through
I did a lot of community service work
through my Theta Kappa which was our
local colleges Honor Society and I had
gotten sixteen thousand five hundred
scholarships in u.s. dollar from that
and by the end when it was all said and
done my scholarships were null because I
spent as much as my allowances were
because you know it's segmented in two
years
spend as much as my allowance is where
the rest was forfeit because I chose not
to go to school anymore yeah because you
were in high ticket closure because I
was in high technical in program and I
was on a fast track to success right
what aren't I need school for you know
the three years I spent trying to get
into Canada well that was the biggest
waste I mean if anything I feel horrible
that I spent the 22,000 my father's been
years saving up weights oh okay well
hold on let me get this straight because
I got to figure out how much
IIIi don't do this I did the same thing
with Garrett I don't do it I don't have
the wounds but let me let's talk about
how much the decision cost because
people you're listening at home you
promised the dream you don't know what
this could cost you you know what it
could man tells you what it could get
you but he doesn't tell you what it'll
cost you okay sixteen thousand five
hundred dollars for their scholarships
then you get how much shaved up from
your gas station job it was I'm gonna
rough estimate 10 grand from a gas
station money ten thousand dollars
yep and then you you spent the college
fund that your dad had saved for you
which was twenty two thousand dollars
yep all this in u.s. dollar Wow Wow
it was so the biggest chunk of that was
the college because that was I think
like seventeen thousand five hundred
Canadian and then there was like a
freaking nine hundred dollar parking
permit talking about highway robbery
with the parking that they got there one
kilometer away from campus by the way so
that was awesome but so in total that
was what 18 yeah so eight hundred plus
so do you know how much do you know how
much all that money equates to I die
happy I mean all I know is that the
college was the biggest single expense
yeah then just right recurring expenses
you know cost of living that's right
Ralph to destroy me and then also the
opera mean that's not even factoring the
opportunity cost because I chose not to
work because I wanted to put all my time
outside of school into focus yeah I need
to focus on htc what it could have been
working part-time up to 20 hours as per
my student visa allowance mmm of course
that would have just been minimum wage
which at the time was like 14 something
for student wages I think yeah but it's
yeah yeah but yeah so still not still
not terrible I mean for like the six
months I was there that would have
amounted to something at some point so
ya know I came home with forty bucks
oh that uh how many years or was it a
year about a year that it took that for
all this to happen so it was about I
think from June to December so six
months six months for all this so six
there was the 2500 from joining HTC
which you know I made that decision and
then there was the inner circle which
was 2000 plus five months of the two
hundred bucks a month so one thousand
yep yep so a thousand plus the two
thousand and then after that was HTM so
of course you forgot closures in black
which sounded like it was two thousand
dollars roughly to go yeah just with
plane tickets and all that fun stuff and
of course souvenir money into was in
there so that one's kind of like you
know irrelevant to the HTC experience
but it's totally relevant to the HTC
experience like yeah dude no you're you
you you take too much I appreciate your
attitude and I think other people will
appreciate your attitude too but you
have to realize Dan's the one who like
brought you out to closures black I mean
he's the reason you went you wouldn't
have gone to Vancouver just for giggles
okay so to that twenty five hundred two
thousand plus a thousand three thousand
plus two thousand and then high ticket
millionaire I've got to go about this
yeah so here we are we're finishing up
our you know affirmations or whatever
you want to call it prayers
then yeah prayers and then we get to the
part where you know he releases HTM and
the benefits he mentioned before anyone
signed anything so I know I can describe
this is you know you get I could leave
gear might have mentioned it to you get
like the boat ride down the river and
then yeah yeah he remember here
mentioned that it was packed on there it
was it was very packed on that wall in
Dan's yacht or whatever is Rio
yep the rented one I gotta say that was
pretty cool
never been on one before and it was just
I know me and my my girlfriend loved it
so I was happy to make her happy with
that and we both every time we look back
I'm like the whole like experience with
all the fuck-ups and everything we're
like yeah but at least we got to go on
the oddball
so I think so there's that but yeah that
was that was kind of cool actually so
anyhow I mean that was a fun expensive s
boat ride with how much a high-ticket
millionaire it was for the month that I
paid for because I stayed from it was
technically October through November
which is when I stay for I stay till the
end of November but they were going to
keep it as one even though it was over a
month just because October you know Dan
was actually right after CIB he went
just on a personal vacation and they
were like okay yeah you know you won't
have to pay for it the additional month
since technically we're not doing
anything and ever you know that's fair
enough right so I'll give them credit on
that one so November when things kick
into gear I'd spent an additional twenty
five hundred USD on HTM so by now you've
spent ten grand on Dan lakh products I
just totally about ten grand on Dan lakh
products the opportunity costs totaling
with scholarships and everything else of
just kind of wasting time on this HTC
thing is $50,000 yeah I don't like to
hear that it's not about you facing it
it's people who want to join look guys
this isn't a cheap assistant 2,500 bucks
it's 2,500 bucks then it's in $2,000
upsell then it's a two thousand dollar
or one however you can afford it
closures and black thing then it's a
$2,500 a month
upsell after that and then you have to
factor in the opportunity cost of what
all this is going to take you before you
may realize like Garrett and Anthony did
that it wasn't getting them anywhere
so no III really these numbers are
important because people live in a state
of fear and shame I cannot tell you how
many people emailed me to go hey I don't
even know why they email me it's like
I'm their priest or something like that
because they don't want to make it
public they don't want no I totally get
that like they just want to tell
somebody because they go hey um I'm
$50,000 in debt I can I will come on the
record I what don't want to say and say
anything because I'm so ashamed of it
listening that's what it is they want ya
they're like they're like finally
someone who's saying that this stuff
isn't working so I don't feel so bad I
don't feel like on the loser you're not
you've been essentially preyed upon by a
what I think to be let's be legal here
careful here whoo I think to be an
unscrupulous marketer so so yeah I'm
trying to remove the stigma of this
stuff and get more people talking about
these predatory systems because the more
you talk about it the more Garrett talks
about it the more people say hey this
happened to me too
I'm not ashamed of it it's it's some it
was a part of my life you know and I can
I can help other people in the future
yeah exactly and again nobody again
nobody forced me to join HTC force
magrunner before turning to attends he
forced me to join HTM they were all my
decisions and I accept those and the
consequences thereof were massive to me
and of course I just I'm more than happy
to finally frickin share at least on a
larger public audience scale what my
personal experience was going through it
in the way that I've you know personally
handled things so and the consequence is
specific to my case of course so for me
I gotta say the worst part wasn't even
like the money because I mean I'm I'm
young enough I'm out there enough to
where I can you know still choose like
I'm going into the trades now which I
found I loved so much more to be honest
I don't even know
I wanted to go into sales because I'm an
introvert [ __ ] that I mean I gave it a
try with some places in town that they
were sales places I gave it a try for a
bit and I'm like why I don't enjoy this
even it like I mean some decent money
later on using what I learned from that
newer coach that I had hired and then I
actually of all the expenses I mean
that's the one I don't regret but I just
didn't enjoyed sales in general so I'm
in the trades now I enjoy that and I
know that a couple of years I'll be
making decent money with it no words
happy oh I want to do electrician work
that'd be awesome that's great man hey
yeah I'd like one of the things I'm a
big fan of his trades school like oh
it's so much cheaper than freaking
lawyers and dude it's actually fun
here's the thing I'm trying to break
people out of the mentality that you
have to be rich to be happy
that you have to be you know these a lot
of these gurus they like talk bad about
jobs that don't make a ton of money
interesting I mean even with electrician
plumbing HVAC and if you're really damn
good at it carpenter you you can make
six figures a year doing that [ __ ] easy
oh yeah but they belittle it though they
go hey that's the part I don't
understand cuz it's like well sure like
I you know I can't do the same job if I
wanted to do it in Morroco I can't go
there overnight but I mean the thing is
with the trades is that once you get
certified in Canada it's the Red Seal
you can do that anywhere in the world
yeah it's just you can't stay for a
weekend you'll have to stay like six
months minimum probably and you know or
most likely summer cruise when they need
the extra help but same principle just
different type of work it's more
physically demanding of course but I see
you're adding demonstrable value to the
world which there's something to be said
about that whereas a lot of these laptop
lifestyle people what are they doing
what are they actually doing if you're
taking another person's gas-station
money you're not adding demonstrable
value to the world well that's the way I
see it now is I
specifically chose the trades because I
was just kind of done with feeling like
they almost had to like screw people
over to get what I wanted yeah and I was
like instead of doing that I'd rather
build something to what they want and I
still get paid great for it and they're
gonna love it because you know if they
choose to live in that house for 15
years then you know they'll get daily
benefit you know it's a thankless job
that I don't care it's something I chose
because I'm happy with is like you know
you don't think about who sets up your
lights you know you just turn on the
light switch and it's fine but I if you
can make a hundred thousand a year doing
that and I don't have to work a retail
I'll do that any day so yeah that's
that's my thought on it and I mean for
one to two years of schooling to get
that taken care of like hell it's theirs
you can almost avoid I can't of course
this doesn't apply to everybody you can
almost avoid debt doing that if you get
a head start in high school and work a
part-time job save up some money and
there's so many scholarships for the
trades it's unbelievable especially
women they get some there's skullet
there's a lot of scholarships for women
in the trades - there's two girls in the
class I'm working with right now for
what I'm doing for carpentry and then my
second year is gonna be electrician and
they're great at it
so I mean it's not only an exclusively
male thing which I know a lot of people
also think about so I'm really glad I
really happy you said that cool that
that's really awesome
so that play so okay I mean I guess the
one thing we really haven't talked about
what yet which I guess we need to get to
is when did you get out of HCC when did
you realize like oh wait this isn't
working
yeah so that's during the Kavon events
last December it's been a year already
yeah it's been here already
mm-hmm so I may just think of my life
over what happened was of course they
separated it got pretty ugly
specific
because from what I heard there was a
some sort of agreement between Dan and
Kavon where Kavon couldn't do something
along the likes of HTC even though he
co-founded it it wasn't only dan that
made HTC it was Dan and came on and then
kayvon made his exit and then came on
did it anyways and then you know he
started in recruiting recruiting people
from within HTC as well and Dan didn't
like the battle on his turf so he
released a video which was taken down
shortly thereafter that specifically
said or these very closely to you know
the HTC community is now declaring war
on
kayvon it was I mean holy [ __ ] I wish he
didn't do that even for his own brand
because people sent death threats to
came on which was not cool and yeah
death threats so yeah that's why they
took that video down pretty fast because
that was not a good situation at all and
people got super hyped up just to go
help and to destroy it came on image and
brand and community and whatever he was
trying to build it just crippled the guy
in any way necessary anyone who followed
him anyone who spoke up about it removed
from the group you're no longer part of
the HTC community so the guy runs a yeah
yeah it was pretty intense and then when
they realized let him that's also when
they realized that maybe this wasn't a
good idea they took down the video and
then they stopped banning people unless
someone elicits lee said you know some
like justin is an example I'm not saying
someone said this but you know the
coupon thing is better than HTC then if
it was something along those lines you
were out but if it was like guys why are
we doing this then you weren't
necessarily kicked down anymore it was
just up to the community to decide what
to do with you you know and all the
people that were defending you well they
were kicked out already so
so I mean and as for the people that got
kicked out well one they didn't want
back in but two for like I think there
were a couple people that tried to see
if they can get back in anyways they
were denied access which then they
started getting a bit upset about that
because now this thing that they paid
for which was in advertising supposed to
have lifetime access to the rice cooker
now they're out well they wanted
ramifications for that so they went off
and started their own Facebook group
specifically just to hate on the HEC
community the irony and that is unreal I
know but just crazy should happen and
during the middle of that I was like
alright I'm done with this I've wasted
enough of my time of money on this
I got a I'm out I'm had now so I left
and I was very pissed at like everything
at the time I was pissed at the world
pissed at myself pissed at HDC and then
eventually I just came to the
realization that well [ __ ] I dropped out
already like I dropped out in November
because I was neglecting my classes so
much that I was just straight up failing
in lies you're too busy focusing on HDC
I couldn't miss it I mean I missed more
days of school and I you know couldn't
miss you know try and get a new
influencers when the other one didn't
really work out or that wasn't making
money and I was I've had better working
my way towards a back-up plan and so it
was just pretty pretty sad in his own
right how everything turned out because
if anything the only thing I had left
after that other than $40.00 was my
girlfriend who why Jesus Christ taught
me write that in there that she's
definitely not with me for any sort of
money or anything like that side I love
her very much and she's everything so
she's still to this day is so and she's
helped me on my rebound back up so
I've been working like mad hours to try
and make back that money as fast as yeah
it might be time to put a ring on that
dick
hein alright so that's a good girl yeah
stay with you through thick and thin
yeah exactly
she's everything more so whoa oh boy hey
man that's a pretty good place to leave
it
do you have anything I always say like
two things number one you know Dan locks
is listening to this right now so say
something to seafood please if your
final balls deceive you
I mean if Dan personally or D someone
weird guys mentor someone for my
Desmond's or anyway anyone close to him
someone from HEC we're to be watching
this right now I just have to say like
and this is gonna catch everyone who's
watching this off guard but I'd first
have to say thank you actually for
essentially teaching me to [ __ ] up so
bad or no again I made those choices but
the consequences of following through
with everything that I was doing I've
never worked so hard in my life to
rebound from anything I mean I'm going
to the gym now my daily schedule is 8 to
3 attend my carpenter classes 5 to 9:30
at night for winter hours I'm working at
a lumberyard and then from 11:00 to 1:00
in the morning I'm at the gym then
before that no way and how was I that
busy so they hit they let you hit rock
bottom
yeah they they taught me how to do that
pretty good side so if anything thanks
for that I guess and yeah next time I'm
just gonna have to I think I'm just
gonna have to stick out of it next time
I'm not gonna go back for seconds I
think the one catastrophe is good enough
for a lifetime so yeah yeah man you
learned that if it looks too good to be
true
unfortunately it is yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's that's good and
then what about to the people a debt to
your bros and your sisters sorry I'm
being a little tongue-in-cheek people in
Asia it's cool it's cool
so to people my htc I'd have to say then
you know of course I'm I'm sure some of
you automatically just I mean the people
that are really in tune with HTC they
just automatically hate me right now
just by default
for the people that you know maybe are
giving an open year maybe keeping an
open mind about some things I have to
say you know of course I'm happy you
listened because this is my real story
I'm back in the United States I lost
everything I even lost the chance to be
with the person I love permanently I
have to figure it out now and try and
find a way to bring her here so just be
aware watch yourself make sure you're
doing what's right for you not big not
doing something because someone told you
to do it I know you can think
independently I know you have it in to
have it in you and for the people that
have already left
just please consider sharing your story
because you know the more the more
testimonies we have you know the more
real it gets and I know you know what I
mean when I say that so we both sat
through the same thing and Garrett too
for that matter so I trusting you to
know what's right for you in your
situation and just circling back to the
people that are diehard HTC you know
just I'm just going to respect your
opinion something that I know you're not
allowed to do so that's that
[Music]
[Music]